can you go uh to the fridge to the
freezer and get the candy bars I had in
there I put some candy bars oh part of
the story it's the Shelf you had a day
where you and Stevie like I don't here
were putting candy bars up your [__]
yeah every there a photo of that those
are the good old days those the good old
days let's get candy bars
out is that why you brought candy bars
yeah that's why I brought candy bars I
put them in the freezer first of all I'm
on an ABC show now I'm not sticking
candy ball yeah you are man I brought
here for old time we talk about it yeah
you're going to put candy bars in your
butt oh my God the big kind yeah I
didn't know they're big kind yeah yeah
yeah small kinds too twixes Twix cuz for
like a mini okay okay I don't know which
one but say this okay can I say this
okay I swear to God I'm not sticking
[__] candy bars in my B yeah you are
no why would you do this because that's
who you are Bobby this is who you are
I'm a different this is who you are I'm
Different no you're not hateful anymore
you're still
sing I'm not saying go all the way you
try to pull them back out how about this
oh you know what I will stick it in my
butt you know why great great we I can
edit this thing hey sweetie you can it I
think strategically you should go for
the Twix the Twix baby all right please
don't put that payday in there what I
will all right I'll I'll stick you know
me we're editing this part anyway you're
not editing it you'll leave it in oh I'm
not leaving it in you will for sure
leave it in because you're a
man oh
you me but maybe I had you wrong I'll
stick a [__] candy bar in my butthole
cuz I never saw I you never saw you've
heard about it you by way my Netflix
special is out right
now Netflix I mean it's like let me say
something oh my God Bobby
Bob the loop is Bobby oh [__] oh my God
Bobby sweetie careful slowly in in I
can't I can yes you can that's not in an
[__] at all that's in the [__]
butt I'm not scking in smell it smell it
if you want to smell it you SM first
stick it in then I'll smell it if you
stick it I'll smell it smell
it smell it smell
it the let me work the courage let me
work up the
courage this is so ridiculous smell it
smell
it no it smells like chocolate it does
smell like chocolate you you have a
clean careful slowly Bobby slowly George
what the [__] slly do that slowly my
god look look it's it that's it okay
okay okay
okay [__] it out sh out Twix good
this episode is brought to you by
Twix the Great Taste and shit's out
easily oh my God your [__] out the Twix
my goodness oh my God God that was
amazing I show right now holy [__] I've
never been able I've never he's never
even allowed a finger of mine up there
all right cuz not chol enough it's not
chly enough how quickly was he able to
convince you old is that's what comedy
was in the old days you want to hear
something that I did I was I was uh I do
a sports podcast punch Sports I Skype in
cuz I used to do it here and then I
moved to New York so I Skype in and I
was I take shits all the time and I just
like suddenly like are are you [__]
while you're doing this podcast and I'm
like that's a oh okay that's a different
one um and then I'm constantly [__]
showing my dick and stuff and so I was
[__] and lisis Gomez was on was in
studio and he was like and I take my I
wipe and then show it to the camera like
already disgusting and Lou G was like
Hey can you take that the [__] and put
it under your eyes like you're a
football
player and I was like you know but Lou
like I can already see on your face
you're considering it cuz you know it's
funny and the shower's right behind you
and you can easily shower off and so
yeah I just do that in my face and then
I was like and then I showered oh my you
know the funnier things going you got to
[__] do it I know but Ari look at
this yeah I got a call yeah from ABC
yeah you know what ABC is for stand for
yeah always butt
chocolate they said stop they said stop
just ease up on the [__] that you're
saying you use Twix instead of payday
that is can't be doing like that man I'm
a different come on man I got to dude
television's dead Bobby I know but I got
to stay on a [__] thing so I can make
enough money to buy a house oh okay
why I know I'm not like you into the
wild all right and like [__]
corporations but you know thing right
now is I you know my dad's going to die
I need another house for my mom to live
in you there's things that I'm looking
in the future I want to marry K have
kids I want to do things man is that did
you just propose was that how you did
it but you know I want to I want to be
able to like you can still do that and
stick [__] up your butt you can be who
you are you are who you are they know
who you are what do they tell you what
do they tell you I don't want to lose
this thing that I have and I just want
to keep it cool right you know that you
know what you actually do have
what Pure
Freedom and you're losing that that's
what you're losing I don't think
sticking a a Twix up your butt is really
anything that doesn't that's craz but
that's not racist yeah there are worse
things that they're going to look for
than sticking chocolate up your butt
like at the weed store they give you a
free joint you get a baby with a child
yeah but it's a they were cute white
babies I remember too I feel bad about
it who what's the cutest race of baby
black babies all the you say girls
always say black babies you think Asian
right I do think Asian second very close
second see girls always say black babies
I I've always s Asian babies are the
cutest and then you know then they grow
up yeah yeah yeah yeah yeah you could
just keep them that way I understand
that but the thing is is that what you
don't realize is that you look like a
baby that you
just
inflated a blow up baby I'm a blow up a
baby really good like a bike
pump that's really good black babies
girls always say black babies yeah CU
they are they're Asians are pretty close
though cuz they're just very we overfeed
them when they're young we're just
really round we like them round that's
why I love that but white babies are the
ugliest thing what 90% of white babies
are gross looking yeah because they're
they're like they're too like Gastly
looking pres presidents to me that looks
like Harry S Truman they do look like
little presidents yeah like exactly not
not even like cuz they're bald they're
bald their eyes are big and yeah they do
presents yeah white babies are present
white babies are I've never held a baby
except for C-section babies they always
come out looking perfect I hate it they
I don't hate it but I'm just saying
they're perfect ask if it comes out
through the vaginal Canal the head's all
deformed and you know they look all just
you know csection baby big head though
C-section baby yeah but that's your
that's your it's deformed no that's your
race that's your Filipino race the head
is stay deformed it's just a momentary
like as it com I'm not being racist but
that's just where you you're from the
country of origin I you would have blown
I mean I would have felt sorry for your
mom if she had to birth that head no two
babies C-sections yeah one of the babies
had two heads that was that was a big
issue yeah I mean was her vagina even
normal now or what no C-section the
tummy man oh that's right my bad my bad
he doesn't know what that's what I was
asking I don't even know what C- section
is where they they they put a hole in
the tummy and they pull it out that way
why why don't they do it the other way
um because times the Mom isn't able to
birth a normal bird no this is this
conversation is happening also with a
parent and a six-year-old somewhere in
the United States why don't they do it
the other way same parallel grow up
now you going do a call back because I
did the thing with your head of your
head thing now you're going to do a call
back to I have to a call back all right
that's fine I'm going to let you have
one call back thank you one call back
Jesus CHR Jessica what Jessica on your
coffee yeah yeah because my girlfriend
got me the coffee and Jessica bought it
I know Jessica's her friend Oh I thought
you did that you said your name was J he
has he has my um best friends doing
errands what do you say when you get
called what do you say your name is do
you say
Bobby sometimes I don't no what do you
what's your go-to I'll say something
that they can't even write go yeah yeah
yeah and they'll go what and as they
start writing it you're like there's an
accent over the
O you're not doing it right yeah ZT and
they go what and but yeah I do um weird
names or you do Andrew right I and I
don't uh I don't support corporate
coffee are
you excuse me no I'm just K know are you
are you are you getting famous now oh my
God you know it's one of those things
where do you feel it yes do you feel it
no dude no no no so you when you walk
down the street no one goes hey can I
get a photo with you no you know what I
don't like uh this is actually something
that you I know you know I don't like it
when someone looks at me and says to
their friend or goes and goes that's and
and then their friend goes
oh yeah yeah yeah yeah I can hear them
do that right I've had that happen if
any you have to have that all the time
if anything just come up to me and just
go hey man whatever say whatever you got
to say and then leave there's nothing
more uncomfortable than I see someone
staring at my face yeah and
going is that yeah it's so I've had this
before is that yes is that and then you
see their face go like
this like you're angry about it right
you're like what did I do what did you
see me that you didn't like you know but
can't even do that because that's not
even open so you just see like that
negativity Nega I always after his shows
when I go on the road with him and I go
to the women's bathroom after your shows
and I hear them giving their
assessment and I can't say anything I
couldn't I can't [__] be like shut up
[__] you record that can't you record
that I mean I I should oh that's such
great material I know I know but I I
can't handle it he can't handle that I I
I just think that if they're there and
especially if I thought I did a good
show but you know you did a good show I
understand that but I still you know I
just I take things personally man dude
you can't no I don't take any I don't
care you really you're like Ari in that
way I don't revie I don't read reviews I
don't listen to that stuff like the cast
on our show they're all upset by some of
these reviews that I can't read that
stuff I don't why would I why do I care
what one guy thinks that's so weird to
to like give credit to somebody that's
like one person that's like here's what
I here's my assessment dude you could be
the most acclaimed journalist I don't I
don't know why I care why would I care
yeah if a bunch of other people are like
I I hate it too I'll be like no that's a
bummer but I I would that that's more
affecting that would more affect me in a
community more than one person typing an
article what about people you got to
[__] you
know you got to get a bow one thing if I
was Asian I'd make white people
bow one [__]
you I love that we everybody thinks
Bruce Le's tough Bruce Lee wasn't about
being tough yeah Bruce Lee was a light
to
immigrants before 196 [__] 8
everybody that was any other color but
white you walked around like in the
shadows you walked around like Harvey
Weinstein in the shadows yeah after
Bruce Lee came he opened up the door to
immigrants immigrants had a voice
especially [__] Asians yeah Asians
were like [__] with me now [__]
I got an uncle who's got Stars what I'm
saying like I'll [__] your world up
Asians had a way that's what Bruce Lee
was Bruce Le a hope for people black
people went crazy how many black people
do you ever see that think they're
Chinese you ever see they eat rice with
chopsticks and [__] we the shoes infused
into the Hip Hop New York they [__]
them up those black people got [__] up
by kung fu movies if you grew up in the
early 70s the Asian you loved bro my
mother took me to a Santa Ria dude
because I kept saying I'm moving to
Asia I had the shoes I had the white
shirt with the buttons I would go to CH
oh I had the white shirt with the blue
or black with the shoes the high cut I
used to I used to [__] burn incense
in my room and my mom with a bowl of
rice all I want is rice you can't eat
rice you can't eat rice all day you got
to eat meat yeah and I would say I'm
eating rice show me a fat [__] chinan
and she would look at me you're right I
never seen a fat Chinese guy just boot
yeah yeah except for Buddha yeah it's
like this it's like um you know I don't
know these kids that get these things
it's fine I'm happy for everyone that
gets it okay but there are just certain
people right that it's just a
given all right you did 25 years of time
into this thing all right and you were
always in it you were never like some of
these guys yeah I I went away for 10
years and I came back you know this this
guy was like me we were in the pocket
when do I always see you why because
it's not because I mean I like seeing
you but it's because you and I have
never quit we never quit yeah we're
always just oh there he is he's just a
part of my reality because him and I are
both guys that refuse to leave the game
we got nowhere to go we're like Richard
G to go got nowhere to go I can go to
mountain tops I can go to cities go all
over the world if you would had
somewhere to go you would have gone
already no but here who puts up with
this [__] abuse who puts up with this
people choosing us Netflix not giving
you a special but you're following Paul
Mooney for a year who the [__] could
they to decide that's why we're so lucky
you and I have something that no other
comic has me over are you ready for this
you know what you and I are what all you
have the Air Force you have the Army you
have the [__] Marines Navy SEAL you
have am I Navy SEAL we are the Navy
Seals hear it when [__] gets danger
danger [__] gets danged who do they drop
out of a helicopter us the Navy seers of
com we're real
surean picked us that'll never ever
happen again so who the [__] is anybody
to judge me is there a picture of me in
an improv not really there's not a p you
don't see me on any shows getting
interviewed by Conan you know whatever
what I'm saying I've come to that
agreement that's another thing that's
interesting is that I I go to Facebook
right or my Instagram whatever social
media and I'll scroll through like you
know these younger guys on Conan and all
these Jimmy Kimmel all these things I go
oh congrat that's great and then it
always in my back of my head like I've
never even been
invited yeah I'll never go I'm on a show
now right Network show they have that
upfronts every year two year two
upfronts they've had so far right two
yeah do they invite Bobby no they have
never been there and all they talk about
is diversity and I mean I'm on the show
which is great that's good and that was
great but you know it's like just for
laughs Just for Laughs never been no me
neither oh now they know yeah but you've
never been to ltin Montreal never never
even they said they didn't like the
twitch I did with my hand one year
that's an actual note that was actual
one year Bruce Hill well I remember one
year he came out to see me like six
times and then the last time he was just
like this is just no way and I remember
my manager Abby I'm still with her she
like yeah sweetie I'm sorry a noo again
this year and I just remember going how
many years have you been with Abby for
20 plus and who's left with Abby no one
else loyal just you I've been with Matt
Blake for as long as the same thing I
don't leave my people that's aaz yeah
you have to you have to I'm loyal I'm
loyal also that's a when I see people
switching camps I don't like it I don't
like we didn't have a lot of Asians man
we had a uh there was a rumor of an
Asian when I was first
what was his name I'm not sure what was
the rumor what was the rumor the
rumor was and I've talked about this
before I've talked about this before
um they had yeah they had a rumor that
there was an Asian kid right and this is
after cuz we got a Latino Kid we got a
Latino Latino not a family one kid
congratulations one guy one guy uh
Nicholas was his name and he had a
little bit of light facial
everybody was fired up about
that fired there was a lot of rumors and
stuff going around about that um cuz
yeah people have never seen that on
children you know was like what mean
light hair on the face yeah like this
people were like he's trying to grow a
sideb burn on his on his chin yeah so
when I was on the wrestling team in
Middle
School um penas penus right they're cuz
penisus was 60% Filipino mhm they're
wrestling Team all the kids had
mustaches oh yeah all Filipinos have
mustaches by the time they're 11 I mean
literally we're female and male is it
like a hand print like a fingerprint
almost we just grow mustaches like not
but we don't really grow the rest though
what we are like Manny Pacquiao
mustaches we all even the female always
mustaches but I remember like wrestling
against them the first time and they all
have mustaches right and we don't we
have we're like we're kids you're like
bro our mustache but our team was so
good yeah that we we beat them even me I
we crush them my
brother when he ever did um Chris is
that his name Steve
Steve close well there's only three
that's John yeah yeah Steve Steve almost
killed Steve almost killed the Filipino
out there wow but my brother had no
facial hair and here's this old man with
a mustache that he's fighting against or
wrestling against and my brother snapped
him on the ground we're like yeah old
man you know what I mean that's what you
get I'm only 14 I know but it was
amazing but anyway so anyway so the F so
the rumor of the Asian though you heard
a rumor yeah they had a rumor that there
was an Asian boy in Slidel Louisiana
which was probably about 17 miles
away and so we had to get over there
yeah you know we were fired up and we
thought about it for a couple weeks and
then we started me and two of my buddies
cut grass man this kid Danny yeah uh who
was a good friend of mine and he had
some he had a couple of different
deficiencies but he's he's doing okay
now you know and he um
we raised up some money saved up some
money over about two months and then we
caught a taxi over there yeah and we
went to this place where they were
supposed to have you know this Asian boy
Chad I want to say the name was Chad I'm
trying to think I have to text somebody
proba Chang does that
sound Chang Chang yeah to Chad Chad I
think right do you ever sound you ever
see him does that sound no it doesn't
sound it sounds it doesn't sound
plausible it does it does it doesn't
sound plausible because I've never Asian
godam chat yeah there are in Southeast
Asia there you go it's either um I think
it's either Tai or oh well then heate
bro
jetmate the rumor so but so we got there
and it wasn't there it was a uh it
wasn't there it wasn't he was the name
is from the city city of Chester England
so probably no probably yeah yeah and uh
yeah we went there and it was just like
a laundromat somebody had opened up like
a new laundromat or like a cleaning like
uh right but there was no was it the
Asian run laundry mat I don't know that
could have been maybe somehow that got
diffused when by the time it got us you
know I mean this is way pre- internet
you know right right right this is back
when you what was the first do you
remember the first time you ever saw an
Asian In the
Flesh man I feel like it was a man yeah
I feel like it was a man with glasses on
yeah but did I could probably draw a
picture of him but I don't think that
I please
I could but I don't think that I could
tell you when how old were
you after that I mean I guess I kind of
gave up on it after the yeah yeah
yeah after the noow of chat yeah but you
would think that you know go you know
saving up money taking a cab to go see
chat you don't see him that you would
years later ke to what when you're going
to see another asan so then when you see
another Asian at airport or whatever you
would go oh my God and that would be in
your thing but that's fine yeah yeah I
remember uh went to afca one time as I
got a little bit older and I was like
holy [__] you know a lot of Africans are
black you know yeah yeah and I was
like and that's when I realized Like
Heaven is mostly going to be like black
and Asian people you know it's not going
to be that many white people there A lot
of Indians Chinese and black yeah yeah
it's going to be packed China has what 1
billion India has 1 billion and they're
dying are they down pretty quick I mean
it's going to be packed up there when
you think about it well you think about
this too think about this I thought
about this is that you know how you know
when like white people they have pets
yeah they do funerals and they go we'll
see you in heaven whatever you think
that all the cats that are left and dogs
that's ever lived on planet Earth are
going to be in heaven too cuz if it is I
don't want to be there bro bro imagine
that just just everything that all the
bees that ever existed all the allergies
I mean it would just be
yeah are you friends with Asians at home
uh yeah how many uh that isn't this is
the weirdest question you're the second
person to ask me how many friends I have
of a minority group but was it asked by
a minority knew yes if I knew the number
do you know how [__] awful that would
be if I capped you guys if there was
like a governor at like
7 I have Asian friends but I don't know
I don't count my high school is like
half asian you didn't have a choice oh
really where'd you grow up uh Manhattan
New York City yeah I I know what
Manhattan it looks like LA California
yeah well I said Manhattan New York City
okay that's fine yeah I know that's did
you hear what I [__] you [__] said
bro so you were half of them were Asians
yeah it was it was like it was a public
school but it was like half for smart
kids and and I swear to God the school
like half the kids got in with grades
and then half of the kids got in because
you had to let anybody in because of
public school and I swear I God half of
the school was [__] Asian right did
you get angry about that or no no I
didn't get angry but it was like clearly
we know who earned
it and who they had to
accept any Asians you preferred what are
what are my Asian hierarchy I have
actually an
Asian and it's changed recently after
going to Asia oh [__] cuz I went to
Japan and I was I was like Japan is
number one you know I was kind of
indoctrinated with like the Western
ideology of Japan right and
um I I go to Japan and I have the best
of several things I've ever had in my
life in Japan I had the best steak I've
ever had in my life hands down wow I had
the best pizza I've ever had in my life
Pizza strata in Tokyo I swear to God
isn't cheese a a um a wanted commodity
then they're always making [__] up
everything's a problem with them right
it's like the Godzilla Che everything's
an issue right they're like they're
really just like anxious people like
it's all going away and those comicazi
they just don't know how to [__] land
I think that's what it
is oh let's go keep going keep going
push through to Jaan push through it
push I go to Japan and I'm like I'm
having the best of of like several
things were the best I've ever had
right but I found I felt like I went
there and I didn't meet a truly Japanese
person or find how they actually felt
about the world meaning everything was a
mask from the gisha to the the [__]
Pizza guy like it was I'm going to
perfect other people's [__] or I'm going
to wear a costume that that is how I
should act in the world but I don't know
who the [__] you really are and then you
start to see their porn and [__] and
you're like
oh oh God you restrict people and then
you cause them to go crazy like and and
it was so weird like even the women
there I was talking to a couple of these
Japanese women that had lived abroad and
they came back and they were like it is
an odd thing like the men here don't
want us to be sexy they want us to be
cute and and it was weird and then you
start to see the girls were kind of like
cute about [__] but they weren't kind of
like owning their sexuality there's no
like there's no like Latina Japanese Pi
it's like in their sassy and [__] with
the [__] F but like super hot about
it never pull out a knife defend their
boyfriend
never never dude that har car would be
amazing all
right but with a with a little pocket
knife a man like a little butter knife
whatever but so it was just this weird
thing so I went there and I was I
thought I was going to have this amazing
experience I went to that [__] that
horseshit sushi restaurant the the Jiro
Dreams of Sushi which is dog [__] it was
the worst Sushi I had the
entire abute dog [__] absolute dog [__]
and let me tell you something and let me
tell you something I came I spent
$1,000 I spent
$1,000 in in in 25 minutes it was $500
for my girl $500 for me and let me tell
you something I was so I I I'm curious
about the cultures I go there to learn I
was so [__] nervous in this place
that I was going to do something to
disrespect them or like be rude by
accident I bought a suit just for this
place okay just for I have a whole
[__] suit we're there on time I'm
screaming at my girlfriend she is
running in heels because I didn't want
to be late cuz they said if you're late
you could lose that reservation we are
so excited she's like a big like food
Enthusiast and we go in and it was
almost inedible no really almost
inedible how heartbreaking I'm that that
morning we went to the old we went to
the old uh fish market right they have a
new fish market like3 billion that they
made and it was amazing you saw like the
tuna auction it was like it was really
sick and we went to the old one to have
sushi and that was the best sushi I've
ever had in my entire life that's the
place and it was unbeliev it was cheap
the nervousness of being in there affect
the no it's the Wasabi it's you're just
if you just you're just snorting M
Wasabi that's what it tastes like when
you eat there and you know what they did
recently I was so happy last week they
took away his Michelin stars that [__]
oh holy [__] dud it's a racket dude you
don't even let Japanese people go it's
like you have to be at a fancy hotel to
get a reservation it's the whole [__] is
is nonsense it's a sham it's a sham it's
a [__] sh [__] sh and let me say
something I knew this about the movie
because if you saw the sushi in EO yeah
you know how like you're as an actor or
you're even documented they put makeup
on you yeah they did that [__] to the
food the food wasn't even real it's not
real in the food if you look at the food
it's glossy right there's like sparkles
on it almost it glows almost I just
thought that was the quality of the fish
no dude it's Hollywood [__] magic
remember how you was like everything is
about the rice yeah dude I'm not going
to lie the rice was bomb the rice was
bomb the rice but you're going to get
bomb rice everywhere you go but let me
tell you something let me also tell you
something and I'm in a room full
evasions right now and you guys will
understand this I'm not spending $1,000
on
Rice SP $1,000 on Rice like that is if
that isn't the whitest thing like if you
found out that a white man spent $1,000
on Rice right like you like how did they
ever colonize anyone like [__] like this
is $1,000 for Rice we're not going to do
it the tomago was good but that's egg
it's like why am I spending the mackerel
was good and then that's it everything
was too much it's hard to make mackerel
not good is so Mac's already [__] Mac
very is a stronger tasting fish okay I
was
livid you sold are you sold on like the
other types of restaurants like Noma or
um these other ones that cost like she
wants to go to this one what tell them
about the one in Denmark oh you land at
the airport BR no not Magnus is in
Norway whatever dude you no it's in
Denmark it's called Noma it's been like
a top Renee read you have to drive 5
hours into the forest then you have to
sleep there in a that's the Norway guy
that's m whatever that guy is this is I
know the whole I know the whole hustle
here keep going I already know I already
know what it's also snowing snow of
course of course of course it's snowing
why wouldn't it be snowing what else you
have to battle of moose go you know how
you paid you know how you paid $1,000
for just basically rice you get a 30
course meal at this place in the middle
of nowhere if you give me 30 peanuts
that doesn't you know what I mean it
doesn't it's the what the [__] but like
you're going to like it because you have
no other options yeah it's true right
it's like you're in the forest and
they're like do you like it you're like
yeah I guess cuz there's just trees out
there like so you have to eat it yeah no
I no I won't do it I'm sure it's good
but part of that is like you go through
the whole journey so you think it's
better than it is yeah I don't know if
you understand this as as a woman as
much as like we understand as men like
trying to get laid Yeah is so much
investment that by the time you do it
you're like oh my God this was worth it
but you traveled into the forest for 5
hours right you did all this thing you
know what I'm saying yes I know what
you're saying boom so we just just serve
it if you give it if you give it and
it's good right away then it's good when
I don't want it yes and I still eat it
it's good the [__] penin what what is
it called palone I didn't want it but
then I ate it so it must be good y 5 4 3
2 1
why are you talking like that hey man
bro I'm singing a song in the beginning
you don't interrupt me until I [__]
introduce you
man um we got Kila my beautiful Kila my
beautiful [__] Island Queen from the
mud rivers of of the Philippines we've
got um wait does the Philippines have
mud Rivers we got two dimensional face
Gilbert can't see me if he goes to the
side he disappears I'm gone
it's like a line is that a Brown Line be
a great character on Charlie Brown we
got uh we have right here Richard
Ramirez he's back's he's back
nightstalker is back yeah nightstalker I
actually don't like how he's in the
closet I know and we got uh there's a
girl in there that's
like accom George Kimo that's how you
pronounce it and um we got um a very
special gu we've had him before this I
think this is the first time we've used
no we've used Assa a couple of times
but this is his um fat
Lando from from I'm not going to there's
a new movie called you already CL fat
Star Wars and he's fat Lando and um oh
I'm fat Lando there's going to be umat
Cloud City you're fat Yoda [__] that's
who you
are oh yeah you can't even get on Luke
Sky Rock's back Luke Skyrock is like
Yoda I don't know if I
get how about we walk together bro it's
good it's good it's good I asked for it
I asked for it yeah um so we got Eric
Griffin back and um he's on a new
television program called I'm dying up
here and it's on Showtime and uh and my
special comes out July 7 oh no we're
going to do that [__] dude I'm sorry but
I don't know BL out your load it's so
unorganized that I'm not sure no see
that's the thing in the chaos structure
asan inter turn you got yeah yeah this
is structur River over here I don't know
what we're doing yeah yeah yeah
and
um when I get my beard transplant which
is what I'm going to do I'm going to use
I'm going to use your knuckle
hairs I mean what the [__] you going to
say that St me [__] mustache you have
on your face you going to talk about
this [__] let me finish are you out of
your mind right now let me finish I know
I do look like I'm
in evolved fully you know what I mean no
this is like right before the in the
werewolf movie right before the guy goes
run you know yeah yeah you don't want to
shave that [__] or wax it I've tried
then it turns into your butthole yeah
yeah yeah oh my God that's so weird I
just noticed that yeah it's really bad
because you're such a big guy that
there's just so much to look at here we
go so I just I slowly noticed first of
all Bobby per capita you're way fatter
you know what I mean what do you mean
like if you did like proportionally yeah
proportionally you're just like a lot
okay okay see this don't make fun of me
from my dog this is 1950s dog
yeah a water hose is going to come out
next
yeah you got to pick and choose your
battles you know how many [__]
battles she could pick with me but the
video game thing you don't how how long
has it been since you've heard anything
about the video game cuz he doesn't play
them anymore yes he does all day Eric
not the good ones not with
you you got to playing Donkey Kong and
[__] in here if okay do you scream like
him when he plays yes no you don't no
cuz I hear you oh oh my God you know
baby he screams louder than me yes I'm
yelling we having a great time you don't
know how much we missed Bobby but you
know what to your credit he is a better
human being I can tell he's like more
focused I can't play Destiny with you
because I'll tell you why okay I I I
gain resentment deep resentment I gain
um I I start like kids on you know when
cuz there's kids I play with on Destiny
them yelling at me and telling me what
to do oh yeah it was like literally kind
of going what the [__] am I doing Bobby
remember when we started playing it was
just you and I and we were like oh we
got to get somebody else so we got
steveen yeah and then we got like oh
that's when Craig came in we we started
to get all these people but once we
started expanding into like people we
don't know I'm right there with you we
were yeah but here's the thing but you
guys suck yeah but it's
not we do we do su I mean when did you
ever win anything yeah yeah yeah this
one really ask I to hear the painful
crying I but the fun of it was of losing
all day Eric cuz we were playing
together it was the camaraderie of it
but here's the thing 6 a.m. in the
morning we played for 7 hours tring to
you ever been to the lighthouse no I'm
never going to right why would do you
want to live like that I I listen I
totally understand what you're saying I
I no I get as equally as frustrated with
this [__] game I'm playing and I'm
like they're doing like trials or some
[__] and I'm like and I'm like I hate
this I'm not having fun like I'm
literally not having fun because there's
no way to get better at it like I don't
care like I change controllers different
guns why would you want to because I
like playing with you
guys that's what it's all about yeah
Bobby don't you remember we became
friends because we were in the Middle
East playing Xbox on the road that is
true can you guys find a different
interactive game other than Des
screaming and we were going to do a
podcast together I see that I see that
you
that's what we were going to
do until this yokoo came in here [__]
ruined it but I'm not
bitter I remember when we went to All
Things comedy together I know we had a
meeting yeah I was in the car when you
made the phone call and I told you to go
to that meeting and you didn't the
second time around whatever yeah anyway
what's done is done who bought the mics
when done is done wait Eric when was
when did you buy a mic oh oh see listen
okay baby baby baby baby baby listen you
are the best thing to happen to this guy
I recognize that him and I this room you
think this room would look like this it
would be crazy in here if it was just
him and I we wouldn't be doing the
podcast be playing Destin I still think
that you guys should do a podcast
together and I've always said it's not
too I want your [__] pity podcast
yeah you did a thing last night that was
very European you kissed my hand three
times absolutely is that a [__] New
York thing he thought you were king jnun
that's what yeah he said he got confused
yeah I was pay I was paying respect to
the dear leader
you no no I [__] like you dude I like
I've always liked you i' I've been a fan
of you since day one and when you came
in and you started eating that bull dick
on op Anthony I was like I'm a [__]
fan yeah and why because you're free
[__] Spirit you're a fun guy got good
energy you got great energy and that and
I know you're not going to lose that now
but just say don't [__] lose it
because you coming in you're wild and
your and your free spirit and you're
kind of like me cuz they call me Chrissy
bug chaser cuz I like to chase
fck and what I mean by that is you know
guys homosexual Community they go and
they have guys who don't have AIDS have
sex with guys who do have AIDS because
of the feeling of chasing the bug and
I'm not a gay guy but but I do chase the
bug I do go raw dog I'm actually dealing
with residual uh diarrhea right now from
antibiotics I took for long-term chyia
yeahia take but I'm good to go right now
and I don't TR what's it what's it
called what's travada now it's basically
a prophylaxis for people who are let's
say if you in a relationship with a guy
with HIV
and so to continually have to continue
to have sex with them without getting
the got it got you can't no condom you
can do it with no condom I mean if I
think about it I can do it with no cond
yeah it's a prophylaxis right but that's
still I feel like that's still like just
playing Russian no that's what I'm
saying because it's the bug chasing
that's what it's about I don't do that
anymore I've been cell I've been Cel
weeks I got a blood job in Denver though
I
will he's had CL about three times
recently like CVS is like his cheers he
walks in they know his name just toss a
bottle
and they know what's up but I but I've
made a commitment now to my family and
to myself to just you know I'm celibate
I'm only going to have sex with a woman
who I think could potentially one day be
my girlfriend yeah that's what I'm doing
and guys on the side so and guys on the
side yeah yeah but so then you um you
had an addiction do you think I was it
was a full full-blown sex addict a full
sex addict you know just unprotected sex
with every just wild just really living
life crazy are you going are you
treating that with meetings and whatnot
like poed up groups and stuff I went to
one and the lady told me um she was like
you know you're not you're not as sick
as you think yeah um she was like but
you know try celibacy and it's been
eight weeks besides the one blowing in
Denver I've been celibate with women um
no I don't know about guys yeah there's
a couple raisins that say it's like
oatmeal you have sex with so many women
sex with so many women that like ra if a
couple raisins slipped in that oatmeal
he wouldn't notice so many women we call
gay guys raisins if a couple guys
slipped in there like raisins he
wouldn't taste it there's a dude that
does our podcast I can't say his name
that's just like you really yeah yeah
handsome very funny like you right but
is in kneed deep in puss puss yeah right
I see for me guys like Yannis I'm sorry
for putting us no no I'm a married kid
I'm no he's Yanni almost yeah he's he's
almost handsome we get
it if I'm just like yeah if you stretch
my eyes a little farther apart just a
little thing everything's a little
disproportionate right you know people's
faces are like one inch like away from
being a incel yeah oh have you seen
incel photos where like they they just
put the Eyes it's like they they look
like incels but then they do this and
then they're Brad Pit yeah right no
that's just exactly all beautiful people
are like that they just hinge on being
really disgustingly ugly sure just one
one millimeter away from that from that
yeah it's true true is that because God
didn't concentrate when they were making
us I don't know I don't know I I it's
got to be something though right I know
where you're going I know where you're
fishing and I cuz I feel like he right
when he made you yeah he took a day yeah
like he's like get The Chins in right
get the right and all that stuff right
and he concentrated right but with me he
went like this and threw and and and
does this guy need a chin no and he need
a billion of us too yeah lot he says
we're making up just Po and just throw
down white dudes like you he really con
well I think it's I think God's German
that's why and I and I think the wrong
people won the war I'm just no I'm
kidding from
2020 you feel mad about Pearl Harbor
what yeah no I'll never eat Su they're
still the enemy I'm still at active the
Japanese Army no my grandfather I swear
to God my grandfather fought in World
War II and he wouldn't eat sushi to the
day he died he would say that he
wouldn't he wouldn't eat it you know
what I'm tired of that [__] can I say
something think When what when Americans
go it was a snake attack they were angry
about it right but that's war war what
is Emperor hereo supposed to call
Roosevelt and go yeah hello you know
it's me how's the family by the way I'm
going to attack you tomor you know I
mean he wouldn't do that you know that's
a good point that's a really good point
it's strategic yeah no they're they're
sleeping in Pearl haror and they don't
know what coming now go time you I do
I'm not if I'm being 100% honest with
you I do fantasize quite often about
sitting in men's laps but I don't know
what that means
yeah he's got like a s yeah he wants to
get in gu like when he thinks the guy's
really hot he wants to get sit in their
lap he has urges to go sit in their lap
like jannis Giannis is such a deep
thinker and jannis is such a a motivated
guy to read and learn and push the
envelope forward and I can't tell you
how many times when I was with my my
kids's mom when were together and
everything was going well I would have a
deep beautiful conversation like looking
at a tree about life and nature and that
would get me so horny that I would have
sex with my kid's mom so I get turned on
by men but I have sex with women hold on
you get turned on by plants and then
have sex with women conversation so in
other
words yeah I'm romantically I I I would
say I'm emotionally gay physically
straight that's how I would describe
myself or or you could just describe it
as just a fully gay man in the closet is
waiting for his father to die to come
out that's the TRU I think I think
triceps from pushing down the Gap so an
Irish Catholic and I push down I mean
that's that's a rationalization I come
from a neighborhood where it's like if
you're not a if you're not a cop a
fireman or a criminal and you're
especially pursuing an art form I mean
you might as well just be sucking [__]
it's like they just are like dude where
can you're I know you're on grinder and
it's like n guy I got a kid I'm just
like I I didn't want to be a copper
fireman but they're like this is the
neighborhood where cops fire but you
know the the US is really uptight about
casual dick sucking because um the
Philippines I I can't think of one male
family member of mine that didn't
casually get their dick sucked they
don't they don't identify as gay they
have families and they husband they just
casually had their dicks suck in a while
homosexuality was way more prevalent in
the ancient world than it is now I
believe that it was way less frowned
upon people think oh now is the most um
you know best time to be a homosexual
and it's a great time but it's like back
in ancient Greece where Yannis can talk
about that it was every it was way
accepted no problem open it open yeah a
little more open yeah it's a little more
flexible yeah yeah more F I love success
revenge like when I was in high
school when I was in high school right
at the last day of school this the
hottest girl at school went to my friend
Craig and goes I'll see you over the
summer this and that and she comes to me
and she goes I'll never see you good
luck and she just walked away and I
remember
going right and then I remember a couple
years ago she was like in the third row
of a soldout show that I was doing right
and afterwards I hugged her how's life
this and that and when I drove to the
hotel right I had such a Glee yeah right
it's it's and I didn't intentionally do
it but it's like success Revenge you
know it's so good it's so good yeah I'm
so glad that um I have only one skill
set which is humor sure right and I was
and I had all this trauma and all that
stuff but I want everyone to listen it's
just like if you could find that one
thing right that one thing that you're
obsessed about right and to do that one
thing rigorously daily you know your
life could still even with a [__] up
background still turn out good you know
so I've had a lot of those you have a
lot of people that you would want in the
front seat oh my God I have like a list
I have I Revenge fantasies I have a lot
of Revenge fantasies and I have a list
of 1,200 1200 1,200 probably names on a
list of people that I want sell out a
theater
right sell out a theater with the
Revenge you should do it the revenge and
invite them all give them free tickets
that's like that's like a [__] Wilt
Chamberlain number people who offended
you I know I know but you know I'm
trying to even do the math and think how
that's possible is that like three
people a day who said [__] you but it
has to do with um you know I have I have
a mind that's a little delusional and I
perceive things that aren't really real
right right like so if like a comic will
walk by and regardless of what their day
was like or what's going on their lives
I don't know but if they don't say hello
to me right I and I don't do this
anymore but I used to write their little
name in my my heart right like Mark
Marin does say hi to me today right and
he gets into the Revenge you know what I
mean the basket right in but it's still
out of my crazy delusional F fantasy
mind that does that and it's unhealthy
and so I don't do it now but I've that's
how I survived sure do New Yorkers have
those same sensitivities no we you grow
up with a lot of I think Scar Tissue
because New York is such an honest raw
place where your kids the friends you're
with when your kids everyone's just mean
to each other and like sort of the way
Comics are our kids went to Third Street
School on on Third Street in uh like in
like Larchmont border of Kore town so
wait let me ask you this is a private
school no public school it is back in
the day they're no go there anymore but
it was predominantly Korean right like
the kindergarten class was Korean
immersion so like your kid they cuz and
they taught math the way that Koreans
learn math is by by the way barely
listen to what I'm saying cuz I kind of
I don't know what I'm talking about
caution caution but but I think Korean
math a lot like playing the
violin okay y he's the wrong person I
thinke with the same way to play the
violin is how you learn math in Korean
and Asian math is easier than white math
don't take my word on this I kind of
listened at
disorientation Ma math is UN let me just
let me say what I'm going to say okay
all right and you I'm going to call my
wife well no don't call your wife no
because she would know what I'm trying
to say yeah but what you're what I'm
just saying is that I thought numbers
were a universal thing no no no it's not
but it's how you learn the math how you
learn the math is very different because
Korean math was was easier to understand
than than uh Colonial math ah so so they
would teach them math in Korean and it
would and that's why math scores were
through the roof and someone's got to
have my back on this cuz or at least
explain what the I'm F kind of like
Rocky trained and Ivan Drago trained
right right yeah Rocky trained in the
forest with logs on his back yes check
chasing chickens and Ivan Drago had
futuristic and the wires and tubes and
yeah and it it is all based on the
violin I don't that makes sense when
you're playing music you see a note you
don't calculate what the note is you go
oh that's a B I hit a b so they the way
I I took kumons is three and two you
don't go what's three plus two you go
the combination three and two kumons Kum
is a
like tutorial Center you [__] I
was sitting here hanging out the drive
for forever you knew this [__] I wanted
to see your explanation I [__]
this [__] right here I know what
he just did and I want to apologize you
know what he did let the white guy try
to hang himself you just did to my
friend right with sabotage and you made
him look like a fool and he's our guest
and I want you to apologize right now Mr
chush I apologize [__] you knew what I
was trying to say you knew what I was
trying to say but I was bad at it I was
really bad so I I cheated so our kids
couldn't do it either our kids could do
it either yeah yeah yeah I want to take
the time to thank tigerbelly fans
because um we did you guys were
Relentless especially on social media
and whatnot were very relent yeah
hashtagging all that stuff and I some
good news it's not picked up yet but um
you know we won we won the we won the
time slot two weeks in a row nice and
the numbers are really good and um you
know the one thing about the show that
if I'm going to say anything about it's
perfect the showrunners the actors I
have a great time on it it's hard for me
to figure out how to become me on that
show to do what I actually do I might
not have be able to do that you know how
like you know how funny you can be yeah
right and then if you get a part where
it's like yeah I got to play so you're
in this part and there's not much you
can do outside of that you got to
respect what the writers bring and go I
don't want to misrepresent how they see
the picture cuz that's it's their
project it's their money yeah so I can't
go out and go crazy I mean that's the
but you know what at the end of the day
you know I'm happy to you know be in it
and uh you don't have ice how do you not
have ice in this we don't we've never
had ice have our fridge is from the
1980s how do you not have why do you
need ice I was going to make another
cocktail then I I yeah well you keep let
me just cuz you know I'm not drinking a
vodka hot
soda Tampa how do you not have
[__] hold on hold on I feel like I
learned everything I need to know about
you
guys when when you wake up and you want
to drink you just go I guess I'll have
lukewarm water yeah okay so say wait
here's no no stop friend stop friend I
want I want to stop you in your tracks
right now okay okay we have um rituals
that we have in this house okay okay and
what you're implying rituals rituals
rual not RS all
right all right let me say this yeah I'm
trying can you make this quick I want to
use
this all right my girlfriend and I right
we love cold beverages oh really you
know yeah but but what we do is we put
it in the god this is cold we put it in
the refrigerator can you put everything
in the [__] refrigerator
yeah yeah I can't believe you don't like
that do you realize that would be a game
changer we're also Asians and Asians
like proper face you're Asian yeah
Filipino who dude I don't like the way
you said that yeah she's Asian dude um
she's just mixed with a little bit of uh
French say the other part Bobby she's
half
Egyptian is that for real half Filipina
I love Egyptians I met a med shout out
to you my friends wherever you are
whatever desert you're hanging out in
right now he's in the Middle East by the
way I'm not saying that as a racist
thing he is out there he he's actually
out in Abu Dhabi or something so
whatever desert you're in not a racist
thing um God bless you and take care
okay this should be an interesting
cocktail someone want to go to my
sister's house and get
ice is it far she a block away you know
I I'll tell you another re thing is is
that we just don't use ice because I
don't drink you know that right no but
you drink fluids yeah yeah yeah but you
know we so we what we do is this okay
just just hear me out okay what we do is
we buy a bottle of water like this okay
yeah and then we stick it in the
refrigerator the refrigerator I don't
know if you know how it works but can
you start making ice maybe yeah it
chills are you sure there's no ice in
there there's no ice sweetie we've never
had ice we haven't made ice in 5 years
yeah do you understand yeah that half of
your listeners right now are going hold
on you guys don't have I like that's
like it when we finally get it it's it
feels like such a treat like when I go
to my sister's house a treat it's the
art of withholding she's from the
Philippines so when I go get to my
sister's house my the first thing I go
to is her crushed ice ice ice machine I
can't even say that it's the most
delicious thing ever and I sit there and
I just crunch ice for like hours yeah
yeah yeah yeah you know you can have
that every day right I don't want it
then I won't enjoy it fre I can I just
say this where do we get one what do you
mean our fridge no is there a machine
that I can buy yeah yeah Bobby there is
actually I bought all of them I love ice
I've had I've had like three different
ice makers I'm thinking about getting
one installed in my garage uhuh cuz I
want the hardcore like the crush crush
ice Sonics but what does ice
do it makes this
drink science alert sence Al what it is
what it is is this is that what I'm
saying is is that I know when you put
ice in things it Waters it down or makes
it
cold just makes it cold if you drink it
quick enough makes it cold so that your
tongue doesn't go hot that tastes like
vomit vodka okay I can't believe I can't
believe I got to drink this quickly I'm
gonna get [__] hammered on this
podcast I'm trying to chase the ice yeah
yeah let me say this okay next time you
come over I'm bringing my own ice no no
no I don't trust you I don't trust you
that I that's a challenge cuz let me say
this right now okay I'm a man of my word
okay hear me everyone back back up all
right let me say this right now
[__] you will have varieties of
I you guys have like you have you eyes
with different like like cold grapes oh
we can freeze some grapes or water you
can freeze
water we don't have the ice ice maker
thing cubes tray have the tray d do we
get one of those you don't even have ice
maker trays if we had an ice maker tray
we'd make ice [__] not BR look it's the
old one they are that fridge over
freezer top regular Bott what's cold in
there uh packs
of we might have something there we
might have something there yeah go get
them yeah yeah blueberries mhm how old
are these blueberries uh they're pretty
new they're pretty new yeah they might
be a little frostbitten though so good
luck yeah yeah I'll take it you going to
put frozen blueberries in there
something I also have Frozen coconut in
there my God this is so this is why he
would win a race war this is insane race
War what you're doing it'll chill my
it's as cold as
I yeah all right and flavored yeah this
might be the new thing so ridiculous
right there all right enjoy your
beverage that's not that bad actually oh
really yeah a little blueberry hint
that's actually really
good yeah so I get booked on um the
Oddball Comedy Festival yeah and I find
out that summer of
2016 yes this beautiful summer of 2016 I
remember it like it was yes a couple
years ago a couple years ago
yes and I can't I couldn't believe they
asked me to do it but um so we go I go
to the airport and it's Sebastian monos
scalo was that the airport Port Tom was
there I think Dan Cook was there and you
know we were supposed to get our own
tickets so my manager Abby Juju she's
Jewish she wants to save money so she
always gives me coach always she honey
it's not a big deal there's no
difference right yeah yeah
so now I remember yeah yeah so then
these guys get first class yeah so I'm
I'm talking to them in the you know you
know G yeah we giggling first class and
they all and I'm like now I blush and
I'm going oh my God I got to walk by
them right and you know me let me say
something walking by I don't know how
Christ felt when he was like you holding
the thing and throwing rocks but it felt
you know similar I I would assume the
only thing I regretted in that moment
was that I wasn't already better friends
with you because then I would have
enjoyed it so much more
you know did you just feel sorry for him
at that point no like I cuz with a comic
you already like they let you know what
kind of person they are so there's some
Comics who would have given off the vibe
of like don't make this a thing and you
kind of like if you can pick up on
people's yeah you know body language and
stuff you're like all you'd be like but
he was playing into like he was talking
about it like I'm so embarrassed and I
was like that's a you should be you know
you're a piece of [__] go back there
yeah so yeah yeah that's what it was
yeah they were like booing did you boo I
think they were Boo and then we told the
flight attendant to bring you stuff like
go give this pillow yeah well no you
came back and threw a pillow on
me he took a first class pillow and it
goes hey use that you know what I mean
and it was just so embarrassing but then
that's when I knew that he was playful
but here's when I knew that I really
liked him and that he was a good guy is
is that apparently we were supposed to
arrange our own rides from the airport
we were in Austin yeah to the hotel
right and everyone got off the plane
first class you know when your friends
are in first class and you're in colge
you would think that they would wait for
you to De plane wasn't Ally on the
flight too yeah yeah right no one did
straight into their limos they went
right into their limos that they their
people set up I don't have a limo
nothing I don't know how I'm going to I
don't even know where I'm staying all
right so I'm like walking I don't see
anybody and I walk outside and I see Tom
standing there with his limo driver and
he says I just assume that you don't
have a
ride and I go correct correct I'll give
you a ride to the hotel who [__] I don't
know who the I'm about to cry who the
[__] does
that I kind I mean no let me get who
does
that I mean not only
we're not war
buddies we weren't Nom together you I
wish I was you know but um I don't know
him that much I don't know him and he
does that that's [__] dope bro like I
I would probably hurt somebody for you
thanks buddy yeah you're welcome man a
wonderful
guy do you know what I thought I
remembered though tell me if I'm wrong
about this yeah I did make the
Assumption you didn't have the car and I
waited yeah didn't you come down and go
like oh like where's my car
oh he was like is my guy here
and I was like did you book a guy he was
like no I was like you don't have a guy
oh I I I mean a normal comedian would
have fired it [__] people for no dude
they just you know no it's no they they
they hung me out to try are you now most
Asians as you know are really good at
the martial art which is your favorite
like of those okay now we're getting to
it now we're getting to the nitt gritty
of it
all um just stop no you ask the question
I may I answer you throw the Stars what
is
[Laughter]
it um I'm Korean so delicious is it not
Taekwondo exactly I took Taekwondo when
I was a kid yeah Master Hong Kong Kim
was my instructor a fat perian [__]
Taekwondo Kim no he was a he yes I was
no actually I was pretty skinny little
kid at that age I was and then I got can
I ask you a question yeah you like the
Andre ausy look about that the head
here's the thing man the the thinner it
gets yeah it's good look but no if if
it's when you're thinner and you let it
go longer it just looks thinner so like
if you have hair you go like oh it's
just parting and falling like you got to
if if you don't go short you're really
you're not doing yourself any right I
mean you can't let the wind pick it up
well you do what poly does and just get
the the the thing what what does he do
he he take he what's it the the implants
I can't do it I just can't do he's going
to get beard implants I'm going to get
beard implants really what stop stop
stop stop why would you I'm serious why
would you laugh like that tell me what
you're so I understand what are you
planning on doing getting beard implants
which is like a hair transplant hair
don't grow
hair are you serious yeah that's a good
idea I looked it up how much is it is
where to go is it a lot
6,500 that's not bad at all and will it
be like everywhere now can I just say
this yeah
just don't tell people that I'm getting
it done I know I'm seeing it on this
podcast I understand that but Comics
don't listen to this so when I have a
full-on beard I want to show up and have
people go oh yeah he naturally could do
that you hear anywhere else not much no
no on like maybe two in his leg Yeah
they take the hair from the back of your
neck and they they they put it into your
face and then you shave it apparently
and then you just let it grow wild I
want to look but you got to make sure it
go it goes everywhere right I'm not
going to do blote like I'm in [__]
thought
talking Chernobyl I'm not going to do
the Chernobyl thing I'm going to that's
pretty wild dude I've never heard of
that what people get it I looked it up
on the internet is it popular among
Asians okay yeah because we can't do
like I can do this so what I'm going to
try to do is grow this out these tips
down here so it does a Fu man cheu and
really perpetuate that look
yeah